pour cinq hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
aider dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
bonsoir à tout ça nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 18 novembre
réouverture prochaine des centres de
vaccination en france en vue de la dose
de rappel contre le commis 19 annonce
tout à l'heure du porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent alors que
les voisins européens s'organisent en
ordre dispersé pour lutter contre la
cinquième vague l'allemagne vient
d'annoncer introduit un des restrictions
pour les non vaccinés le portugal
pourtant pays le plus vaccinée d'europe
réfléchit à réintroduire des
restrictions
alors qu'en autriche le confinement
obligatoire pour les non vaccinés a
provoqué une ruée vers les centres de
vaccination alors la vaccination quoi
qu'il en coûte un mal nécessaire ou une
atteinte aux libertés intolérable en
étant vos réactions sur le compte et g
d'ayrté france
est la une également la crise migratoire
à la frontière pologne biélorussie le
premier vol de rapatriement de
clandestins irakien a élu aujourd'hui au
bord de l'appareil à 4 130 migrants de
retour à erbil au kurdistan irakien une
opération symbolisant la reprise des
contacts entre la biélorussie et l'union
européenne est saluée par la russie et
ce alors que le kremlin appelle
bruxelles à ne pas accuser moscou de
tous les maux
la france doit-elle construire plus de
réacteurs nucléaires comme le propose
emmanuel macron pour la cour des comptes
trop d'incertitudes planent sur nos
capacités à respecter les délais et des
coûts raisonnables la place du nucléaire
qui alimente les débats à l'aube de la
présidentielle et au lendemain de la
coop 26 et si le nucléaire était la
réponse la décarbonation de nos
économies est ce compatible avec l
projets de ré-industrialisation posco
vie de notre économie c'est le thème de
ce soir de l'édito de jacques sapir
et enfin la pauvreté n'a pas augmenté
martel l'exécutif mais pour le secours
catholique la réalité est tout autre sur
le terrain un français sur dix a eu
recours à l'aide alimentaire en 2020
d'après son dernier rapport plus
inquiétant encore vingt sept pour cent
des personnes interrogées affirment ne
pas pouvoir s'alimenter pendant une
journée entière voire plus une situation
alarmante qui touche particulièrement
les ménages sans ressources les parents
isolés et les personnes seules
[Musique]
l'europe est donc redevenu l'épicentre
de la pandémie de kovy 19 db novembre le
vieux continent a regroupé plus de 60%
des nouvelles infections enregistrées
dans le monde et la france n'y échappe
pas avec la cinquième vague déjà là on
retrouve david khalifa devant le
ministère de la santé bonsoir davies est
notre pays a donc dépassé la barre des
20000 cas quotidiens des chiffres qui
ont doublé en une semaine
vous le disiez stéphanie la france
traverse sa cinquième vague en plus du
nombre de cas l'attention hospitalière
s'accentue on dénombre
7663 personne hospitalisée pour une
infection au coronavirus dont 1300 en
réanimation un chiffre en nette
augmentation et pourtant l'exécutif ne
panique pas et a réaffirmé sa volonté de
ne pas mettre de nouvelles restrictions
la question de la vaccination des
enfants de 5 à 12 ans n'a pas encore été
décidée le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent observe elle est un
premier résultat des pays comme israël
qui ont déjà appliqué à cette mesure
avant de prendre une décision écouter
on prend les décisions dès lors qu'on a
des recommandations scientifiques qui
nous disent on vous le recommande sur la
vaccination des enfants lagence
sanitaires européennes devraient nous
donner son avis d'ici la fin de l'année
ensuite il faut que l'autorité française
nous donne un avis on ne l'attend pas
avant début 2011 22 ce sujet est loin
d'être anodin il est normal que les
autorités de santé prenne le temps des
autorités qui prennent leur temps et des
français acquis et s'inquiètent comme
vous le savez en autriche les ânes ont
vacciné avons être confiné une mesure
qui n'effraie pas les france est prête à
tout pour passer des fêtes de fin
d'année serait n'a selon un sondage est
là pour bfm tv et l'express 59% des
français sont favorables à un recond
finement à des personnes non vaccinées
soit 6 français sur 10 qui ne souhaitent
pas se confronter à de nouvelles
restrictions comme nos voisins européens
et toute l' europe 1 qui s'inquiètent de
la reprise de l'épidémie chacun y va de
ces mesures avec la dernière en date un
l'allemagne
comme l'autriche avant stéphanie
l'allemagne va généraliser les
restrictions spécifiques pour les non
vaccinés face à la flambée et des
infections de kobe 19 dans le pays la
chancelière angela merkel annonce
aujourd'hui est que les personnes
n'ayant pas encore reçu l'aide
d'injections connaîtront de nouvelles
mesures sanitaires impliquant notamment
leur exclusion de certains lieux publics
une nouvelle règle entrera en vigueur
dans le pays nommé 2 g/l autorisera
seulement les vaccinés et les guérit à
accéder à des lieux publics comme les
restaurants ou salles de concert et dans
la majeure partie du pays qui écoutait
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
cela commence par un indice
d'hospitalisation de 3 vous savez que
c'est notre unité de mesure lorsqu'il
est dépassé la règle des 2 g doit être
appliqué dans toute la région
c'est à dire vaccinés ou tester lors de
manifestations publiques
vacciner on guérit pardon
une situation similaire à l'autriche
depuis lundi tous les autrichiens qui
est on plus de 12 ans et qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ne sont pas autorisés à sortir
de chez eux chez eux seulement pour
faire leurs courses essentiel pour
s'aérer être physiquement et mentalement
ou pour des soins médicaux avec ce
confinement le gouvernement espère
pousser les récalcitrants à se faire
vacciner seuls 65% de la population a
reçu deux doses en dessous de la moyenne
européenne
en plus de ça dans un mouvement de
panique est générale et bien deux
régions autrichiennes particulièrement
touché par le kobe 19 devons
réintroduire un confinement général de
leur population la semaine prochaine
c'est une première en europe depuis le
printemps merci david qualif en direct
devant le ministère de la santé alors on
l'entend évidemment face à la cinquième
vague air de kobe les non vaccinés sont
ciblés souvent directement par les
nouvelles mesures restrictives dans
certains pays de l'europe allemagne on
l'a dit pays bas autriche en particulier
sur les non vaccinés alors la
vaccination quoi qu'il en coûte un mal
nécessaire ou une atteinte aux libertés
intolérable on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le télégramme d'ayrté
france place au décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler sur ce plateau bruno
megaman chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bon soir
bruno megaman merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés philippe herlin économise
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là et
puis nous irons également retrouvé un
petit peu plus tard thomas bonnet en
direct de washington où l'administration
maiden peine à imposer la vaccination
obligatoire dans les entreprises à tout
à l'heure thomas adam quelques minutes
on vous retrouvera alors l'europe
inquiets de re devenu le moteur
malheureusement de la pandémie la france
est dans sa cinquième vague
officiellement a dit olivier ferrand
c'était prévisible selon vous bruno
meyer ban comment on peut l'expliquer
d'ailleurs puisque l'europe est parmi
les plus vacciner alors on va dire
c'était prévisible mais peut-être pas
avec la même amplitude c'était
prévisible oui parce que le virus n'a
pas de raison de disparaître de la
planète et qu'avec le refroidissement
des températures
le fait que nous revivons à l'intérieur
sans ouvrir les fenêtres qu'on reprenne
une pleine activité sociale et de
loisirs est bien faisait que le virus
allait pouvoir se propager
maintenant effectivement on pensait au
début que le vaccin pourrait mieux
freiner les contaminations même si on
sait qu'il protège parfaitement contre
les formes graves de la maladie on
pensait qu'il pouvait freiner davantage
les contaminations et donc réduire la
diffusion du virus et peut-être même
protéger les personnes non vaccinées
malheureusement nous devons constater
qu'effectivement malgré la vaccination
les contaminations peuvent se faire même
si comme vous le savez une personne
vaccinée contaminé fera une forme bien
moins sévère que s'ils n'avaient pas été
vaccinés alors face à sa cinquième vague
on vient de le dire les voisins
européens prennent des mesures
l'allemagne qui annonce un pass
sanitaire qui s'appelle pas comme ça
mais enfin ça revient au même les non
vaccinés seront exclues un de certains
lieux publics en autriche on confine
carrément les non vaccinés il ya des
éléments d or qui vont jusqu'à 1450
euros avec beaucoup de contrôler votre
réaction philippe herlin moi je suis
assez scandalisé par ce convoi je crois
qu'on est dans une comédie sanitaires il
faut revenir au fait il faut il faut
bien entendre la déclaration qu'a fait
jean françois delfraissy hier qu'elle
président du conseil scientifique il a
dit que les vaccins protègent assez peu
de la contamination du site ces termes
exacts donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça ça
veut dire que le l'obligation vaccinale
masqué en fait que l'on voit avec avec
le passager terre l'obligation vaccinale
n'a pas de sens l'obligation vaccinale
pour les personnels de santé n'a pas de
sens non plus parce que vous pouvez à
vous pouvez avoir être vaccinés et puis
transmettre quand même la maladie donc
ils vont rameuter personnels de santé
soient testés régulièrement plutôt que
d'être obligé d'être vacciné le
l'obligation dati nations qu'en fait
pour les adultes les adolescents et on
pense on envisage de faire pour les
enfants des aucun sens parce que on nous
explique à waimes ils sont en bonne
santé donc ils vont pas faire de formes
graves les enfants feu 0 forme grave les
seuls qui sont morts ccqab adecco gambie
douter mais ils peuvent la transmettre
dans kg mais il est vacciné mais non
mais si le vaccin n'empêche pas la
contamination quel intérêt de vacciner
les enfants les adolescents et les
adultes en bonne santé je rappelle un
chiffre de santé publique france les
moins de 65 ans sans comorbidités ça
représente seulement 2% des décès ça
veut dire que quand on est en bonne
santé on n'est pas concerné directement
par le cos vide il faut respecter les
barrières mais mais mais il n'y a pas de
moi je remets en cause aussi la notion
de confinement on a fait beaucoup trop
et pour moi il n'ya pas c'est pas de gtx
sanitaires qui sont poursuivies ce natif
politique c'est une étatisation de
l'économie c'est là c'est une sorte de
coup d'état contre les population qui
impose des directives complètement
débile comme le fait d'en fermer les
confiner dans fait d'enfermer les
non-vaccinés jeu aussi vu qu'il ya des
préfets qui commence a obligé en france
à m remettre le mas à l'extérieur alors
qu'on sait que ça sert à rien il n'y a
aucune étude n'a jamais montré que le
match à l'extérieur fonctionner mais
c'est un discours de paix pour imposer
des décisions étatiques et mettre les
gens sous l'étouffoir et je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux c'est un problème
de liberté publique ça n'a plus rien à
voir avec un discours sanitaires on va
voir cette première réaction télégramme
à combien de recevoir j'espère qu'elle
va s'afficher dans quelques instants
copap la cata voilà qui nous dit non ce
n'est pas cette réaction c'est pas celle
de michel qui a beaucoup voyagé ces la
vaccination ne protège pas de la
contagiosité de la maladie certes elles
diminuent peut-être leca g et
actuellement nous remarquons qu'il ya
autant de vacciner que de nom vacciner
dans les hôpitaux au nommé garman ça
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai il ya
désormais plus de vacciner que de nom
vacciner chez vous vous à la cie pitié
salpêtrière par exemple alors tout
d'abord rétablissement de la vérité donc
la vaccination réduit la contamination
de troie d'un facteur 3 effectivement
c'est pas suffisant pour empêcher les
contaminations mais ça l'a réduit
deuxièmement la vaccination réduit le
risque d'être hospitalisée par un
facteur 10 à 11 donc c'est énorme donc
aujourd'hui dans mon service de
réanimation médicale il n'y a aucune
personne vaccinée donc fightnews ce ne
sont que des personnes non vaccinées
d'ailleurs souvent qui ont peu de
comorbidité et c'est là le point
important c'est à dire il faut pas
penser qu'en ayant pas de commande vides
et entend plutôt jeune et bien on ne
risque pas de faire la maladie cas
malheureusement effectivement les
personnes non vaccinées
se croyant protégés adoptent le mode de
vie des personnes vaccinées et c'est là
qu'ils attrapent le covin parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui le virus
circule un niveau élevé et
malheureusement pour eux ils ne sont pas
vaccinés ça la caractéristique donc il
s'expose à un risque qui n'est pas nul
alors qui peut être plus faible chez les
sondés sans commodités mais qui n'est
pas nul de faire une forme grave de la
maladie et de mourir et c'est là où
c'est dommage parce qu'ils ont une âme
qui est le vaccin qui leur permettrait
justement d'éviter ce risque de façon
extrêmement importante
philippe herlin quand vous entendez
voilà ses explications assez rationnelle
d'un médecin qu'est ce que vous répondez
vous êtes en plus économistes et
certainement vu que l'économie continue
d'un pays est-ce que souad j'imagine
aussi tous les états qu est ce que vous
vous répondez à ces arguments mais le
vaccin diminue les formes graves ça
s'est mesurée est constaté et les gens
qui sont touchés par les formes graves
chez les personnes âgées ou les
personnes comme les comorbidités donc ça
justifie pas d'avoir une politique
sanitaire aussi et brutal où on va
enfermer les non-vaccinés quoi voilà
donc ces et puis sur les chiffres alors
sur les chais vous dites que n'avait
aucun aucun non vaccinés a aucun
vacciner au malade aujourd'hui bon c'est
pas du tout les chiffres qu'on voit en
angleterre dans d'autres pays en france
c'est vrai que les vieillards ont dit
qu'il n'y a quasiment aucun malade
vaccinées en france bon et on la france
est peut-être complètement à part des
autres pays européens mais ça m'étonne
mais c'est pas du tout les chiffres
qu'on a les autres pays le vaccin
protège contre les formes graves mais
pas de façon parfaite donc il ya aussi
des risques et moi je considère alors
même si le vaccin protège contre les
formes graves je considère qu'il faut
aussi penser aux traitements à ce que
moi j'ai attrapé le co lead on va je
répète qu vide et j'ai été guérie parce
qu'un médecin a bien voulu me filer de
l'ivermectine des titres homicide la
fièvre est tombée à 24 heures et en
trois jours je tire établi voilà donc
donc ces traitements là on sait que ça
marche il ya des pays toute l'afrique
noire l'afrique subsaharienne sauf
l'afrique du sud où on utilise beaucoup
les verdicts in parce qu'il ya des
questions de pas du tout ça il ya ils
n'ont pas du tout été touchés alors
aussi bien macron que la meyze nous
disent il faut vacciner l'afrique et
c'est eux et ils n'ont pas de problème
voilà donc il faut aussi penser aux
traitements c'est complémentaire mais
considéré que le vaccin est la seule et
unique solution et qu'il faut forcer les
gens à se vacciner ce n'est pas possible
parce qu'on voit que ce sont les pays
très vaccinés qui subissent une
augmentation des cas alors si c'est que
les cas c'est pas grave mais aussi une
augmentation du nombre de malades donc
ça veut dire que c'est papa de la
solution unique il faut avoir une
palette de deux traitements différents
paliers
sur les nouveaux traitements mais on va
laisser répondre je sens que vous nommez
garde a envie de répondre alors d'abord
effectivement oui il y à des personnes
vaccinées qui développent une forme plus
grave de la maladie qui sont admis à
l'hôpital nous n'en avons eu dans notre
service mais ce sont des personnes qui
soit ont une immunodépression qui fait
qu'ils répondent mal aux vaccins soient
effectivement aujourd'hui on le sait
qu'avec le temps par rapport à la
deuxième dose s'il s'est passé plus de
six mois il y a une certaine baisse de
la protection c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
il faut pour pouvoir éviter ça instaurer
deux points le premier c'est la dose de
rappel pour toutes les personnes à
risque et notamment de plus de 65 ans
six mois après la double dose et puis
surtout vacciner le plus grand nombre
car les personnes qui ne peuvent pas
recevoir le vaccin pour des raisons
médicales ou qui sont immunodéprimés et
qui ne répondent pas aux vaccins seront
protégés du fait que la circulation du
virus dans la population vaccinée sera
moindre c'est pourquoi il est important
de vacciner y compris certaines
personnes qui n'ont peut-être pas
directement leur ait un risque de faire
une forme grave de la maladie
ensuite concernant le traitement qu'a
pris mon collègue et ami je dirais
malheureusement ça n'est pas les
traitements qu'ils ont guéri c'est
simplement lui même il n'a pas de
facteur de commanditer il est jeune il a
fait une forme mineure de la maladie il
a guéri spontanément ils auraient pris
de l'eau sucrée du coca cola il aurait
guéri de la main de la même façon avec
la même vitesse pas mon cas par rapport
à cas médical exceptionnel mais mais
c'est aussi d'essayer aussi des études
qui montrent que ces traitements
fonctionnent il ya des pays justement il
est punis sinon
il ya les pays d'afrique il ya l'inde
qui règle les problèmes aussi avec les
lentilles le japon aussi qu utilisent ce
produit là qui est très peu touché donc
non il ya quand même des études qui le
montre voilà donc la loire les
différences entre les pays que vous
évoquez bien sûr il existe c'est que
vous
heureusement pour le continent africain
sont une population beaucoup plus jeunes
avec moins de co morbidités alors qu'en
europe malheureusement dans une
population vieillissante avec le dia
mais avec des problèmes
cardiovasculaires avec un mode de vie en
milieu fermé clos et donc tout ça
favorise la diffusion du virus et
malheureusement le développement de
formes plus grave ça veut dire à bruno v
germann que selon vous la fin justifie
les moyens quand on voit que l'autriche
confine les non-vaccinés amont
l'autriche qui plafonne effectivement
qui plafonnait à 65% et qui d'ailleurs
se précipitant maintenant voilà c'est
cocasse avoir vers les centres de
vaccination ça veut dire que il faut en
passer par là sous peine voilà de donner
un petit coup de canif aux libertés
fondamentales individuelles alors je
suis pas persuadé qu'il faille confiner
les non vaccinés je crois que c'est
vraiment une mesure extrême d'ailleurs
elle n'a lieu que lorsque effectivement
en raison de la poussée épidémique
si la couverture vaccinale est
extrêmement médiocre certains
gouvernements arrive à cet extrême mais
en fait on peut parfaitement l'éviter en
améliorant la couverture vaccinale ce
qui est le cas de la france actuellement
donc il est très peu probable qu en
france on soit amené à en arriver à ces
extrêmes globalement peu efficace je
pense c'est bien mieux de modifier le
pass sanitaire actuel vers un pass
vaccinale qui poussera peut-être
davantage les hésitants à se faire
vacciner et puis ceux qui sont
totalement réfractaires malheureusement
on pourra pas aller faire vacciner c'est
leur droit mais jeunes on conseille
amical pour eux pour qu'ils restent en
vie et dès qu'ils appliquent strictement
les mesures barrières ça qu'ils n'auront
pas le droit de sortir le bout du nez de
leurs masques car malheureusement ils
risqueraient de tomber malade et
gravement malade civile ayant eu j'ai
une immunité naturelle qui est meilleure
que celle des vaccins donc il ya des
millions de français qui sont dans ce
cas là donc pourquoi est-ce que la
sérologie n'est pas reconnue dans le
système dans cette politique sanitaire
que l'on voit il ya des millions de
français qui ils ont une unité qu'est
meilleurs voilà donc alors qu'ida plus
longtemps que les verts alors d'abord on
va dire que les effectivement vous avez
raison lorsqu'on a fait l'infection
naturelle mais qu'on a reçu une dose de
vaccin une seule dose de vaccin là on a
l'immunité la meilleure c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'immunité hybride par contre si
on a juste fait l'infection naturelle
une fois on a une immunité qui diminue
avec le temps
comme les personnes qui ont doublement
été vaccinées en fait baisser la dose de
vaccin peut être que vous avez reçus ou
pas je ne sais pas on sert de booster
ensuite à votre infection est
effectivement à ce moment là vous seriez
aujourd'hui dans le meilleur cadre de la
protection maintenant à nouveau je
répète pour vous vous êtes plutôt jeune
et en bonne santé donc vous risquez peu
de faire une forme grave de la maladie
mais pensons quand on diffuse des
messages contre la vaccination aux
personnes plus crédules qui nous
écoutent et qui l ont des vrais risques
de faire des formes graves de la maladie
et bien malheureusement il se retrouve
chez nous et là ils constatent amèrement
et à leurs dépens que s'il avait été
vacciné il ne serait pas venu en
réanimation philippe herlin selon un
sondage 1 et là bas pour bfmtv l'express
près de six français sur dix tout de
même sont favorables à reconfirme en des
personnes non vaccinées comme le fait
l'autriche ça vous évoque quoi parce que
c'est vrai beaucoup de personnes
vaccinées n'ont pas envie entre
guillemets d'être les seuls finalement
le vrai pour la collectivité aussi ça
vous comprenez ce sentiment mais je
trouve ça assez effrayant parce que
c'est la fabrique du bouc émissaire
quand on présente les non-vaccinés com
dcom comme les responsables du problème
et les vaccinés enfin en tout cas
beaucoup de vacciner en sont convaincus
le problème c'est que s'il se penche sur
les les un peu les thèmes que je viens
d'évoquer environ que le vaccin peut pas
être la seule solution surtout qu'il ya
un autre aspect évoqué dont on parle
assez peu mais quand commence à en
parler ça commence à émerger ce sont les
effets secondaires bon on sait qu'il ya
des myocarde et des problèmes cardiaques
qui touche un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont jeunes en bonne santé
il ya plein d'athlètes de footballeurs
notamment ça a été recensée par des par
les journalistes qui sont cons des
problèmes en un match ça fait des
dizaines de personnes dans l'est dans
les ligues professionnelles ou amateurs
on sait qu'il ya quand même des décès
aussi alors il ya la base audrey
vigilance qui parle de 20000 évidemment
c'est pas ces défis cap présumées sur
des gens qui sont décédés après le
vaccin c'est pas forcément le vaccin qui
la cause pour le savoir fois référé
toxiques le problème c'est qu'en fait
pas d'autopsié comme ça on est sûr de ne
pas le savoir et on cherche j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche un peu à
masquer sa il ya des effets secondaires
importants et donc pour moi ça rentre
d'autres la vaccination des jeunes et
des adultes en bonne santé d'autant plus
irrationnel
qu'on vaccine le vaccin je me protège
contre les personnes âgées et les
personnes que les cobras ont milité ça
diminue nettement la spécialisation est
d'accord mais vacciner les personnes en
bonne santé compte tenu du fait qu'il ya
des risques pour moi la balance bénéfice
risque elle est négative pour les
enfants les adolescents et les et les
adultes en bonne santé bon il faut pas
vacciner tout le monde avant d'aller au
portugal c'est important que vous
répondiez parce que ça c'est peut-être
aussi le sentiment pour beaucoup de
français notamment sur les jeunes il
faut bien le dire et là on commence à
voir les pays qui vacciner 5 11 ans est
ce bien nécessaire d'ailleurs le conseil
aujourd'hui académique alizés ben va on
va pas sacrifier entre nîmes et les
enfants pour protéger les adultes qui
ont pas envie de se faire vacciner alors
tout d'abord il faut bien sûr vous
l'avez reconnu le vaccin est efficace
quelle que soit la classe d'âge
maintenant effectivement non le vaccin
c'est un médicament donc de fait il a
des effets secondaires donc évidemment
il peut donner par exemple un risque de
myocardite qui est plus important avec
le vaccin moderne a par exemple les plus
importants chez l'homme jeune ça c'est
tout à fait mais le problème c'est que
si cet homme jeune attrape la covin
naturellement eh bien il a plus de
risques de faire une myocardite que par
le vaccin est d'ailleurs s'il fait la
myocardite cours de l'infection
naturelle elle est plus grave que s'il
l'a fait à la suite du vaccin les mots
car dit on les voyait pas à avancer mais
bien sûr d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que
c'est pas l'heure suivant des données
jamais lyon mais je vous rappelle que
j'ai je le donne et je n'ai pas pu leur
seront donnés hydroxyles eurokin de
notre ami professeur raoul tu as
beaucoup des patients qui avaient l'aco
vide on l'a accusée d'avoir des effets
secondaires cardiaques mais ça n'était
pas du tout les droitiers que leur guide
c'est parce qu'on le donnait à des
patients qui avaient des problèmes
cardiaques du fait de la co vide c'est
la maladie sous jacente qui a fait
émerger un risque éventuel d'effets
secondaires ali dropsy chloroquine mais
si on va faire un détour vers le
portugal a ou on assiste aussi à un
petit rebond des contaminations pourtant
parmi les plus vaccinée d'europe et même
du monde avec 85% du schéma complet le
pays envisage de nous leurs restrictions
on en parle avec pia il est psychologue
clinicienne direct donc de lisbonne
bonsoir pilat il est merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord quelle est la
situation sanitaire dans le pays on
parle d'art d'art bon
et il se passe très bien aussi au
portugal parce que comme vous le savez
bien il ya une grande part cible il a
sept îles sans sanitaires dans la rue et
que il ya du respect les gens se font
vacciner ceux ci fonctionnent vacciner
et c'est l'armée qui a aidé à faire ça
c'est vrai le portugal n'est pas
toujours un pays qui si bien organisée
mais en ce qui concerne la vaccination
ça a été mais impressionnant mans
efficace et il n'y a pas cette dilemme à
cette discussion si les non vaccinés ne
pourront pas rentrer ici ou par là non
il ya un peu la mentalité surtout chez
les jeunes que oui et la vaccination est
nécessaire c'est obligatoire on le fait
pour se protéger nous et pour protéger
la société il n'y a pas il ya beaucoup
moins d'hésitation il ya moins de
préoccupation et il ya moins d
abstinence dans les vaccinations il ya
peut-être un esprit qui fait que oui on
va pouvoir faire sa lessive portugal et
oui vous avez raison c'est arrivé et ça
se présente plutôt bien même si oui les
chiffres c'est plus que 2000 infectés
aujourd'hui et il va avoir un look
tendance et aux as et bientôt un autre
problème du look down c'est que ce n'est
pas populaire et le premier ministre
comme cost oui son budget n'a pas passé
ce qui veut dire il est pas très très
bien assise et comme il y aura des
élections tout début d'année il n'a pas
encore parlé du logo c'était le premier
ministre lui qui maintenant commence à
parler du logo parce que c'est vrai les
chiffres sont
très très très haut et ça inquiète tout
le monde avec même 85 pro sont vaccinés
que ça puisse continuer à cette
vitesse oui oui ce film c'est peu il
faut aussi préciser
puis il n que le système hospitalier au
portugal est extrêmement fragile donc
c'est une forme de nécessité aussi
peut-être pour les portugais de se
protéger
se faire vacciner vous voulez dire que
comme ce soit par les restrictions
soient par les gestes barrière ou par la
vaccination au choix mais il ya un
système hospitalier qui est qu est
fragile
c'est vrai les hôpitaux publics qui
normalement on fonctionne très très bien
il ya un très bon monsieur service
social hôpitaux les gens sont bien aimé
ici avec le co ville ils ont été
débordés c'est vrai il ya eu des gens
qui dépassent et dans des tentes dehors
comme partout en europe se résume ça a
été très difficile dans nos hôpitaux
publics et ils ont commencé à envoyer
les patients dans les hôpitaux privés
comme ça peut-être ça va pouvoir
partager un peu ce poids qui lui
l'incident mans et qui on est obligé de
atteindre tout de suite de son occuper
les traiter les gens
merci à pia il n pour ce rapide panorama
de la situation au portugal bruno média
vans on était un petit peu ébahie
d'entendre effectivement 85% de vacciner
pourtant on parle de london a au
portugal alors déjà c'est vrai qu'avec
85% de médecine et pourquoi on parle
maintenant de confiner aussi là bas
c'est vrai que là c'est un petit peu la
double peine si j'ose dire alors je ne
sais pas que où on est la décision de
confinement ou pas au portugal en tout
cas on en parle mais en tout cas l'une
des caractéristiques de cette bague
c'est qu'il y à un découplage entre les
contaminations qui progresse de façon
exponentielle qui vont atteindre un
niveau que l'on n'a jamais atteint au
cours des vagues précédentes puisqu'il
n'y a aucune mesure de restriction
chacun peut circuler comme il veut
chacun peut aller dans la réunion qu'il
veut
et donc les contaminations vont
progresser par contre il y aura un
découplage par rapport aux
hospitalisations et ce découplage sera
d'autant meilleure que la couverture
vaccinale est élevé et donc c'est très
clairement le cas du portugal et de
l'espagne pour une très bonne couverture
vaccinale cela sera aussi le cas en
france et pourquoi on est malgré tout
relativement optimiste en comparaison
aux vagues précédentes c'est moins le
cas des pays de l'est qui l'a le
découplage n'est pas aussi clair et de
fait malgré tout il faut être prudent
car lorsque les contaminations vont
augmenter si elle atteint un niveau trop
élevé du fait qu' il y a encore par
exemple en france au moins 15% des
personnes qui devaient se faire vacciner
qui ne le sont pas eh bien on risquerait
avec ces personnes parfaitement
d'encombrés l'hôpital c'est pourquoi il
faut absolument respecter les mesures
barrières et faire tout pour réduire la
circulation du virus mais de toute façon
on observe déjà et en observant à tout
instant un découplage jamais on
connaîtra l'afflux massif de patients à
l'hôpital qui fera que le gouvernement
n'aura pas le choix que de faire un
confinement ont sauvegardé la santé de
la population on va aller maintenant
encore plus loin outre-atlantique à la
campagne vaccinale rencontre quelques
difficultés on y retrouve donc thomas
bonne et notre correspondant à
washington thomas le président américain
qui a dû abandonner la vaccination
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 100 salariés
oui cette mesure a été suspendue c'était
la dernière mesure en date décidée par
joe biden pour tenter d'accélérer la
campagne vaccinale qu'il y patiner aux
états unis il ya moins de 60% de la
population américaine qui est
complètement vaccinés au moment où je
vous parle alors que joe biden avait
donc décidé d'instaurer cette mesure qui
concerne des millions d'américains tous
ceux qui travaillent dans des
entreprises de plus de 100 salariés une
obligation de vaccination à partir du 4
janvier prochain ou à défaut d'une
preuve de vaccination un test qui doit
être réalisée de manière hebdomadaire
alors dès l'annoncé de cette mesure par
le gouvernement américain il ya eu
beaucoup de poursuites et qui ont été
lancés par des états aux états unis pour
tenter de bloquer cette mesure ça a donc
fonctionné puisque une cour d'appel
fédérale a suspendu cette mesure de joe
biden au motif qu'elle pose de sérieux
problèmes constitutionnels on assiste
donc à un bras de fer juridique qui
pourrait s'achever auprès de la cour
suprême des etats-unis n'est plus haute
juridiction du pays qui va donc sans
doute devoir trancher sur cette question
est ce que le gouvernement américain a
le droit d'imposer une obligation de
vaccination dans le pays alors le timing
est assez forte puisque je vous le
disais cette mesure était censée entrer
en application le 4 janvier prochain le
gouvernement de joe biden en tout cas en
apparence se montre toujours optimiste
explique toujours que cette mesure est
nécessaire pour protéger davantage
d'américains il explique d'ailleurs que
le retard de la mise en place de cette
mesure pourrait provoquer des dizaines
voire des centaines de décès dans le
pays alors cette mise en place de
l'obligation de vaccination voie est
donc très compliqué aux états unis où
évidemment les libertés individuelles
sont très importantes pour les
américains maintenant à vous restez avec
nous pour aborder la dernière partie du
débat tout à l'heure avec la question
des traitements très en pointe en ce
moment aux états unis philippe herlin ça
vous fait rêver évidemment cette cour
d'appel qui parle d'un d'un abus de
pouvoir inconstitutionnelle de joe biden
on pourrait voir peut-être la même chose
devant les tribunaux en france selon
vous j'espère bien le problème c'est que
la cour le conseil conditionnelle
français les conseils d'état se sont
couchés devant gouvernement donc il faut
à rien d'espérer 2 court terme aux états
unis où il ya manifestement un peu plus
de d'indépendance de la justice bon mais
nécessairement tout ça le cas de
l'espagne avec 85% vaccination ça montre
que le vaccin peut pas être la seule
solution est et je le répète il ya le
cas des effets secondaires qui sont en
train de remonter qui sont quand même
masqué statistiquement parce que quand
il y avait un mort du co vie d'avant
même s'il y avait un cancer ou une
maladie grave s'il est testé positif qu
vide on disait qu'il était mort du co
ville c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve
avec 135 mille morts en france 2,2
qu'ovide alors que les chiffres elle en
italie ils ont recalculé les chiffres et
les gens qui sont morts uniquement du
coc vide c'est 3% tous les autres
étaient morts d'autres choses avec ab
d'autres comorbidités donc alors on fait
un peu exprès de d'exagérer les choses
et et bah voilà donc c'est pas possible
de rester dans ce mot ce schéma de
vaccins comme solution unique justement
je rebondis sur ces chiffres parce qu'il
ya une nouvelle hier qu'ils étaient
assez étonnante on nous dit 5 millions
de morts sur la planète et plusieurs
études c'est paru hier vous l'avez
certainement vu nous disent que ces
chiffres pourraient être sous-estimée ça
pourrait être trois fois supérieure
alors qui a raison qui a tort dans cette
affaire l'avis du médecin alors je peux
certifier que toutes les personnes ou
les 120000 peu près décès en france sont
directement liés au co vide alors
effectivement certains avec quelques
comment militer mais ils ne sont pas
décédées de l'évolution fatale de leur
maladie mais de la décompensation de
leur maladie à cause de la colorisation
estimé youssou diallo très clairement
sous-estimé dans le monde évidemment
dans tous les pays même un accident
c'était en chine vous imaginez en chine
il ya très peu de morts mais évidemment
il y en a bien plus vous pouvez mettre
plusieurs zéros à côté du chiffre de
départ donc c'est largement sous-estimé
à mon avis même trois fois le chiffre
annoncé est probablement en deçà de la
vérité alors on va retourner voir thomas
puisqu'il ya peut-être de quoi mettre
tout le monde d'accord en tout cas
rassuré ceux qui ne sont pas vraiment
favorable aux vaccins thomas puisque aux
états unis l'apparition d'un traitement
développé par plusieurs laboratoires
est en train donc d'être d'être
clairement développé
oui la maison blanche croit beaucoup en
ses traitements pour preuve washington a
commandé 10 millions de traitements à
pfizer de ce traitement qui s'appelle
donc le pacs le vide à 10 millions de
traitements recommandés par la maison
blanche pour une somme avoisinant 5 9 5
29 1 milliards de dollars alors c'est un
traitement qui est donc commercialisé
par pfizer il s'agit de 30 comprimés à
prendre dans une période de cinq jours
alors riser a montré des résultats
intermédiaires sur les tests pour ce
traitement il affirme qu'il ya une
efficacité de l'ordre de 89 % pour
réduire les hospitalisations et les
décès pour les adultes qui sont à risque
il ya aussi un autre acteur sur le
marché de ces traitements c'est
l'entreprise merck là aussi washington a
déjà commandé des traitements puisqu'il
y adela 3,1 millions de traitements qui
ont été commandés par la maison blanche
mais d'abord il va d'hommes il va
falloir que l'agencé américaine des
médicaments valide ces deux traitements
la décision devrait intervenir d'ici la
fin du mois de novembre merci thomas
fili peyrelade une bonne nouvelle pour
les réticents aux vaccins que vous êtes
un d'ailleurs astrazeneca annoncé un
tout à l'heure aux six mètres un
traitement
à l'essai c'est la solution c'est une
bonne nouvelle c'est aussi le monopole
portail d'heure parce que quand on vient
de le voir c'est extrêmement coûteux
beaucoup plus que l'hiver me tim powers
donc si c'est au moins aussi efficace à
l'ivermectine pourquoi pas si ça allait
un peu plus alors là c'est formidable
mais il faut attendre de voir ici parce
que quand le vaccin est sorti nous
annonçait 95 % d'efficacité et penseront
qu'on s'est rendu compte après qu'elle
diminuait et que donc on va avoir un
abonnement vaccinale il faudra faire des
robes d'aider des piqûres tous les six
mois ou tous les ans à vie et quand on
sait je le rappelle qui a des effets
secondaires importants etc etc c'est
quelque chose qui est caché aujourd'hui
mais qui risque d'exploser un peu con
affaire du sang contaminé moi je dis
attention c'est une erreur de vacciner
de vouloir vacciner tout le monde il
faut réserver le vaccin quelle
efficacité démontrée pour les cas
fragile bruno megaman cette pilule ça va
nous empêcher d'avoir ça va nous
dispenser on va dire d'avoir cette
troisième dose peut être vous y croyez
d'abord repréciser les les vaccins n'ont
pas les fameux effets secondaires que
l'on décrit actuellement pour une fois
jamais un médicament un vaccin n'a été
n'a affiché aussi clairement et
publiquement les risques aujourd'hui on
a plus de 7 milliards d'individus qui
ont été vaccinés et tous les effets
secondaires potentiels qui sont pour
souvent uniquement une coïncidence sont
publiés donc on peut être sûr que le
vaccin est parfaitement et efficace et
on va dire avec des effets secondaires
extrêmement fins archives de ses effets
secondaires justement oui on va dire à
peu près les effets secondaires principe
posé des problèmes de douleurs au bras
aussi de vaccination d'un petit syndrome
viral mais qui sont des effets
secondaires habituel des vaccins les
effets secondes à un peu plus graves qui
peuvent survenir on va dire dans les
jours qui suivent la vaccination il y a
effectivement la myocardite il y à
quelques des effets secondaires
neurologiques
et puis il peut y avoir des problèmes
sur les plaquettes de thrombose mais ça
reste des événements extrêmement rae la
balance bénéfice risque reste
extrêmement favorable maintenant quant
au traitement alors oui nous sommes
ravis évidemment qu'il y ait ces
nouveaux traitements d'ailleurs il ya
deux gammes de traitement il ya les
pilules anti viral dont on a bien
discuté il ya quand même il faut le
rappeler les anticorps monoclonaux qui
existent déjà depuis un petit moment
alors la caractéristique de ces
traitements quels qu'ils soient ils ne
s'adressent qu'à la phase précoce de la
maladie c'est à dire la phase virale
donc il ne vise que les personnes dans
les trois à cinq jours après la
contamination dont tout au début une
fois passé ce stade il ne marche plus du
tout donc une fois qu'on développe la
pneumonie ça ne marche pas du tout donc
d'abord faut-il encore se dépister et ce
diagnostic est très précocement ensuite
ils s'adressent surtout et d'abord est
quasiment uniquement aux personnes qui
ont un risque de faire une forme grave
de la maladie ce d'autant plus qu'ils ne
sont pas vaccinés voir s'ils sont
vaccinés évidemment et qu'ils ont été
contaminés car effectivement on sait que
lorsqu'on a des comorbidités lorsque la
unis dépression malgré le vaccin parfois
on peut développer des formes graves de
maddie donc c'est une thérapeutique de
sauvetage pour les aider maintenant en
aucun cas cela ne se substitue à la
vaccination donc il faut pas penser
justement comme comme ça a été dit
précédemment je ne me fais pas vacciner
j'attends d'être contaminés et je prends
ces comprimés car comme vous le savez
vous prenez un risque de dépendre
uniquement de comprimés que vous allez
prendre d'éviter la forme grave de la
maladie il vaut mieux malgré tout éviter
d'être infecté pour ne jamais courir
c'est triste ce risque grave de la
maladie merci vous n'aurez pas fait donc
certainement pas convaincu philippe
herlin que ce score mais enfin voilà
comme d'habitude sur rt france on donne
tout les opinions bruno megaman merci
père la merci à vous aussi et toujours
sur le front de l'est protocole idaho
brésil +2 59% des populations a reçu les
deux doses du vaccin et au moins 73 % la
première des chiffres encourageants qui
ont lancé le processus d'un retour à la
normale comme à rio de janeiro où la
samba rythmes à nouveau le quotidien des
habitants un reportage signé augusta
lunardi commentée par sandra simo
[Musique]
au brésil la samba est de retour que ce
soit dans les fameux concert
traditionnel ou dans les écoles de danse
qui se prépare pour le carnaval 2022
c'est grâce à la hausse des vaccinations
que les musiciens pas six tasses et
organisateurs ont pu reprendre leur
activité
le pass à lithaire est exigée à l'entrée
de tous les évènements fermé et une
jauge à 75 % reste en vigueur pour les
spectacles et salles de concerts ce
groupe de touristes venus de sao paulo
est soulagé pour le plus dur était
d'être privés des concerts de samba
[Musique]
on a beaucoup souffert car avant on
fréquentait tout le temps les rodas de
samba ont travaillé dans le monde yeux
quand le confinement a été instaurée par
là vraiment senti dans la peau
au delà d'être privés de notre loisir
préféré
beaucoup d'amis qui exerçait dans le
milieu ont perdu leur travail sans
parler de ceux qui bossaient toute
l'année pour que notre carnaval puisse
avoir lieu mais là même si on est très
content du retour de la samba et du
carnaval
il ne faut pas trop se relâcher car la
pandémie n'est pas encore terminée
à rio le mythique musiciens moacyr luz
est de retour sur scène après sept mois
d'arrêt avec son groupe samba de travail
adore ou la samba des travailleurs après
que le maire de la ville a donné le feu
vert au retour des jam sessions comme
beaucoup d'autres ce groupe de musiciens
avait été handicapée par la décision des
autorités municipales d'interdire tout
rassemblement
[Musique]
résumé pierre de merde
on va essayer de rouvrir petit à petit
mais on avait tellement peur d'être un
plus dans quoi cela n'a duré qu'une
semaine on y prenait pas de plaisir on
était inquiet mais là le scénario est
différent on prend les précautions
nécessaires
les autorités sanitaires font des
inspections régulières et le ministère
de la santé continue d'intensifier la
campagne de vaccination c'est ça qui
nous a permis d'être tous ensemble de
nouveau à nous les habitants de rio on
veut faire la fête on veut sortir aller
dans les bars être tout le temps dehors
je suis un coach qui nous parle
chahristani
de retour dans les salles de danse de
rio après plus d'un an sans répétition
liées à la pandémie musicien professeur
et danseur de l'école de samba to you
qui ont pu reprendre les répétitions
pour préparer la plus grande fête au
monde le carnaval de février privée
d'édition en 2021 c'est performeur
trépigne d'impatience et redoublent
d'efforts pour proposer une
représentation spectaculaire c'est
désormais un contre la montre qui est
engagée pour que tout soit prêt le jour
j plus d'un million de touristes venus
du monde entier sont attendus à rio de
janeiro pour célébrer la prochaine
édition du carnaval selon les
spécialistes cette fête hors norme
pourrait rapporter près d'un milliard de
dollars à l'économie de la ville reste à
savoir si un tel événement n'aura pas de
retombée au plan sanitaire
au chapitre politique emmanuel macron
s'est adressé aux élus locaux
aujourd'hui un discours tenu en
conclusion du congrès de l'association
des maires de france le chef de l'état a
remercié les maires pour leur action
pendant l'épidémie emmanuel macron qui
en a profité pour défendre son bilan
point par point de la suppression des
taxes d'habitation aux actions en faveur
des coeurs de ville est pour lui
l'opposition qu'on entre les élus et
l'état ne doit pas exister
il y a les élus locaux et le
gouvernement
mais l'état est un tout et j'en suis le
garant il peut pas y avoir l'état face
aux élus ça n'est pas vrai
il y à celles et ceux qui sont
responsables devant le parlement
démocratiquement élu c'est le
gouvernement pouvoir exécutif il y à
l'administration qui en précède il ya
les élus locaux qui ont leurs
compétences et l'état c'est tout cela
et ne peut pas y avoir ce face à face
sous prétexte qu'il y aurait eu d'autres
émergence politique et au fond ma
conviction principal fait que le travail
des maires
des élus de la république
de votre serviteur là où je suis
aujourd'hui
et de tous les fonctionnaires qui sont
au service de notre action c'est de tout
faire pour relever pas simplement les
défis de l'urgence
mais réussir à faire nation c'est-à-dire
embrasser notre avenir
mais aussi
bâti renforcé la cohésion de notre pays
prêt pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis peau d'un éditorialiste bonsoir
alexis david lisnard bon qui prend la
tête de la mf un petit camouflet pour la
république en marche
oui puisqu'il y avait face à lui
quelqu'un qui avait derrière lui est la
république en marche qui venait du
centre et qui n'a pas gagné qui venaient
même de la mf d'ailleurs david lisnard
si les maires de cannes il est en
campagne depuis quelques mois il à
deville it et au national et il vient
des républicains et chose à souligner il
a commencé sa carrière en étant proche
du vice-président de cette association
des maires de france donc il connaît
bien ce système là il faut voir que
derrière évidemment il y avait la
velléité des modèles macron de prendre
cette association indépendante des
maires de france pour en faire un outil
de campagne éventuellement ou moins
ancrée cette politique de la république
en marche dans les territoires puisque
il lui était longtemps critiqué le fait
d'être un président hors sol un
président qui n'est pas ancrée dans les
territoires pas proche des élus locaux
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que dès 2017
et blel macro lui s'était rapproché de
l'association des chasseurs un autre
lobby assez puissant dans la ruralité
mais pour les mères c'est un échec la
preuve avec cette élection de david
lisnard aujourd'hui et au delà alexis
des des ambitions personnelles
un poste on imagine de choix pour poser
dans la campagne
et oui un républicain à la tête de
l'association des maires de france c'est
la continuité d'une certaine façon mais
c'est aussi important puisque les maires
sont ceux qui donnent les parrainages
aux candidats à la présidentielle et
puis c'est aussi à un poste national qui
permet de donner de la voix surtout
quand on vient d'être élu et de pouvoir
peser pour un candidat ou un autre alors
je pense que david lisnard restera
discret dans la campagne pour le congrès
en tant que le candidat de la droite ne
sera pas choisie mais une fois fait il
aura un poste de choix pour bien sûr
pousser les idées des républicains est
donné
une tribu de même si bien sûr
l'association des maires de france
travaille pour tous les maires elle est
apolitique mais ça reste quand même une
position médiatique qui permet d'avoir
une visibilité que n'ont pas les autres
le maire français est clairement là cet
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau pour
emmanuel macron puisque lui n'a pas
réussi à placer quelqu'un proche de
cette maison commune 1 qu'il souhaite
bâtir pour supporter ça sa candidature
sa nouvelle candidature à sa réélection
alexis emmanuel macron donc lé maire
c'est une longue série de rendez vous
manqués peut-il encore rattraper des
choses parce qu'on a assisté quand même
aussi une petite séquence de
calinothérapie aujourd'hui ont
complètement alors emmanuel macron est
très conscient de ses limites et de ses
défauts il ne fait depuis le mois de
septembre que colmater sur le régalien
sur la sécurité sur l'éducation sur
plein de choses en fait il est en train
de colmater les brèches pour faire
campagne à droite toute donc là
évidemment ils voulaient colmater les
brèches et les malentendus comme il le
dit lui même avec les maires de france
on se souvient quand même que ça avait
été un sommet boudé à l'époque il
n'avait pas voulu venir les voir il y
avait eu tout à un psychodrame autour de
ça et puis clairement il ya un président
qui est vu comme
internationaliste monde un citadin coupe
et finalement de la ruralité ce que ne
sont pas les mères donc ils essayent la
de rattraper un peu les morceaux c'est
un peu tard évidemment il est en
campagne donc c'est normal il fait un
discours de campagne que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement verbeux extrêmement vide
aussi de dire qu'il faut une cohésion
que évidemment les maires sont le
premier ciment il a essayé de défendre
sa politique puisque les municipalités
ont perdu beaucoup d'argent avec les
réformes de bale macron alors il a il
s'en est défendu en disant que non tout
ça avait été compensée et qu'il était là
pour les aider et non pas pour que le
président soit contre les élus on voit
bien que la mésentente persiste qu'il ya
surtout une incompréhension finalement
de ces les attentes du pays est aussi
une vision très jacobine du pouvoir très
centralisé très verticale ou emmanuel
macron voudraient décider de tout avec
les préfère qu'il a nommé
d'ailleurs à l'appel lorsqu'il était
président il est toujours d'ailleurs
mais l'idée est de dire je veux
travailler avec vous parce que la
campagne commence et que s'il a tous les
maires de france de beaucoup de maires
de france qui vont être contre c'est sa
politique ça va être compliqué de faire
campagne au local parce que il ya très
peu d'adhérents la république en marge
qui peut faire campagne sur le terrain
merci alexis pour l'art d'avoir été avec
nous
zuma présent sur la crise migratoire à
la frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie aujourd'hui plus de 400
irakiens ont été rapatriés dans leur
pays d'origine après avoir déclaré
l'état d'urgence la pologne à ériger à
la hâte une clôture en fil barbelé
coupant objectif empêcher le passage de
milliers de clandestins qui dit
souhaitait se rendre en allemagne les
migrants qui attendent dans un froid
glacial d'autres opérations de
rapatriement
adrien fond de
la fin d'un rêve mais aussi d'un long
calvaire arrivée à l'aéroport ce jeudi
ils sont plus de 400 irakien a quitté la
biélorussie après bientôt deux semaines
passées à la frontière polonaise le
projet de rejoindre l'union européenne
et finalement abandonnée et c'est un
retour au pays qui est organisée par la
diplomatie irakienne
sur décision du gouvernement irakien
nous menons une opération spéciale pour
évacuer nos compatriotes de la frontière
biélorusse et européennes les autorités
aéroportuaires nous ont apporté toute
l'aide et le soutien possible dans cette
affaire nous avons délivré des
certificats de retour à ceux qui avaient
perdu leurs passeports
l'opération a été parfaitement exécuté
nous n'avons rencontré aucun problème
nous espérons que d'autres vols seront
organisés pour ceux qui souhaitent
rentrer chez eux
ce vol était volontaire pour ceux qui
veulent retourner en irak nous n'avons
forcé personne à rentrer chez lui chacun
est rentré de son plein gré il y a
maintenant un grand nombre de personnes
là-bas à la frontière qui veulent
rentrer
lane au total ce sont près de sept mille
migrants qui sont concernés par ces
mesures de rapatriement et de
déplacement la biélorussie qui s'est
rapproché de l'allemagne au cours des
discussions entre alexandre loukachenko
et ongs et la merkel espère maintenant
régler cette question migratoire avec
les 27
environ 2000 personnes se trouvent à la
frontière dans le soi-disant campements
improvisés nous nous engageons à aider
dans la mesure du possible
et s'ils le souhaitent les 5000 migrants
restants à rentrer dans leur pays
d'origine et angela merkel selon les
accords négociera avec l'union
européenne notamment sur l'organisation
d'un couloir humanitaire vers
l'allemagne et doller germania une
annonce immédiatement nuancé par berlin
la commission européenne évoquant de son
côté seulement des discussions
techniques et si certains rentrent chez
eux d'autres n'ont pas fait une croix
sur leur rêve européen dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi les autorités
polonaises ont annoncé l'arrestation
d'une centaine de migrants qui tentaient
de franchir la frontière
mais en attendant des solutions pour ces
candidats à l'exil les conditions de vie
dans les campements sont de plus en plus
précaire illustrations sur place avec
mourad gazière envoyé spécial pour verte
et internationale
le tour n'est pas favorable pour les
migrants
il fait froid ici
il y à beaucoup de gens plus de 1000
personnes à cet endroit qui est un
ancien centre logistique que les
autorités biélorusses ont mis à la
disposition des migrants maison un toit
sur la tête il fait chaud il y à de
l'électricité et ils peuvent recharger
leur portable et rester en contact avec
leurs proches de la nourriture est
également fournie
mais de nombreuses autres migrants se
trouvent toujours dans la forêt dans des
camps de l'autre côté de la frontière
essayant de traverser la pologne pour se
rendre en allemagne qui est la
destination finale pour beaucoup d'entre
eux
il n'y a pas eu de tentative massive de
traverser la frontière dans la nuit et
l'esprit combatif rac st vivante dont
beaucoup sont bien sûr des femmes et des
enfants qui ne s'attendaient pas à une
réponse aussi féroce de là de la pologne
je n'ai plus d'espoir concernant l'union
européenne nous avons dormi dans la
forêt pendant dix jours il y avait des
enfants avec nous c'est très dangereux
aucun des pays de l'ue eux n'est prêt à
parler de ce grave problème personne ne
nous accepte la pologne utilisent les
gaz lacrymogènes contre des femmes et
des enfants aient lieu garde le silence
la pologne dit aux médias que nous
sommes dangereux ils nous voient comme
des animaux mais nous ne sommes pas des
animaux je n'ai pas réussi à atteindre
l'allemagne et je veux rentrer chez moi
nous avons essayé d'aller en europe à
trois reprises et nous n'avons pas
réussi
j'en ai assez j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé
à la frontière je ne peux pas rester ici
c'est très dur j'ai pas ça je suis très
fatigué je ne veux pas réessayer ma
famille en irak me dit s'il te plaît
reviens quand j'ai vu que la pologne a
utilisé des gaz lacrymogènes contre des
femmes et des enfants j'ai pensé que les
autres pays européens ne serait pas
différent
face à titre de référence nous ne
prenons en compte que les troupes les
soldats que la pologne a modélisé
stationnées à la frontière près des
points de contrôle six hectares quinze
mille soldats et c'est sans compter les
gardes-frontières pondent des services
d'urgence
la police qui se trouve à la frontière
et des environs de migrants ici quinze
mille soldats polonais pour les
surveiller pour chaque migrant
femmes
il y à sept soldats polonais
la réponse de la pologne très
importantes
équipes essaient d'empêcher quiconque
d'entrer en pologne
des gens ont réussi à entrer en pologne
certain romain marchand l'allemagne mais
ils sont rares
et les gens ici se rendent compte que
leurs chances diminuent ce n'est pas ce
qu'ils attendaient de leur
faut une crise migratoire qui inquiète
la russie un sujet évoqué tout à l'heure
par vladimir poutine devant les
diplomates russes le chef du kremlin
s'est également exprimé sur d'autres
dossiers épineux du moment les
correspondances à moscou de vera goffman
crise des migrants afghanistan ukraine
les tensions avec le temps les états
unis vladimir poutine a fait le tour des
sujets brûlants lors de son intervention
à la réunion du collège du ministère
russe des affaires étrangères
un des premiers sujets abordés par le
président russe a été la crise des
migrants la frontière polono biélorusse
pour l'adie mercantile l'occident se
sert de cette crise pour faire de la
pression sur la biélorussie tout en
oubliant ses engagements humanitaires
les pays occidentaux utilisent lac la
crise migratoire à la frontière pour le
no biélorusse pour susciter des tensions
supplémentaires dans cette région est
exercé des pressions sur
minsk et notamment sur le plan
humanitaire
regardons aujourd'hui comment les
services de sécurité polonais se
comporte à la frontière nous le voit
très bien la télévision sur internet
pauvres petits enfants qui sont là
les aspergent d'eau de gaz
et la nuit des hélicoptères volent le
long de la frontière des sirènes sont
branchés la dmr poutine a affirmé que la
russie devait obtenir des garanties pour
sa sécurité à long terme le président
russe a également souligné que la
réduction des tensions politico
militaire répond non seulement aux
intérêts russes mais aussi aux intérêts
de toute l'europe et du monde entier
écouter aujourd'hui cette bonne
coopération qui gagent entre l'ue et la
russie
aujourd'hui se sont installés nettement
dégradée et je lui ai continué à
pratiquer la langue de deux des
sanctions et cela se ressent sur les
plans économique mais aussi sociaux et
culturels il faut que moss elles
comprennent bien que la baisse de la
tension
ici c'est pas seulement les intérêts de
là aussi mais c'est l'intérêt de tous
les pays d'europe à la fin de son
intervention le président russe a
reconnu que le fardeau était lourd pour
le service diplomatique russe qui
travaillent dans des conditions très
difficiles il faut également noter que
c'est la première fois que vladimir
poutine s'exprime devant le collège du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
un haut parleur en de la place du
nucléaire qui alimente les débats à
l'aube de la présidentielle et au
lendemain de la coop 26 et si le
nucléaire était la réponse est la
décarbonation de mots entre nos
économies c'est le thème de ce soir dans
l'édito de l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et des
étés de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts ni
sur la bbc il réalise des hôpitaux visés
et il était nulle part est ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
l'adn de la classe politique qui a pris
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible puis deux années même avec
monsieur alpha condé deux pays étaient
dans une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte c'est qu'on soit bien
des lignes ont aujourd'hui on a une
gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la france doit-elle construire
plus de réacteurs nucléaires comme le
propose emmanuel macron 1 pour la cour
des comptes ronds d'incertitude plane
sur nos capacités à respecter les délais
et les coûts raisonnables la place du
nucléaire qui alimente les débats l'aube
de la présidentielle et au lendemain de
la coop 26 et si le nucléaire était la
réponse à la décarbonation de nos
économies est ce compatible avec nos
projets de ré-industrialisation
paskowitz de notre économie c'est le
thème ce soir de l'édito de l'économiste
jacques sapir
et la pauvreté n'a pas augmenté martel
l'exécutif mais pour le secours
catholique la réalité est tout autre sur
le terrain un français sur dix a eu
recours à l'aide alimentaire en 2020
selon son dernier rapport plus
inquiétant encore un quart des personnes
interrogées affirment ne pas pouvoir
s'alimenter pendant une journée entière
voire plus une situation alarmante qui
touche particulièrement les ménages sans
ressources les parents isolés et les
personnes seules
la cour des comptes a donc dévoilé
aujourd'hui ses notes sur le logement la
police ou encore l'énergie en france
pour le volet énergétique et les
magistrats alerte sur les incertitudes
autour de la capacité à construire un
nouveau parc nucléaire des doutes qui
planent sur les délais les coûts
raisonnables à tenir la cour des comptes
propose notamment un scénario avec 25 à
30 nouveaux réacteurs alors que la
france on compte déjà 50 6 le président
macron avait annoncé il ya neuf jours
vouloir en tout cas lancé un nouveau
programme nucléaire alors ce thème du
nucléaire qui s'est imposé dans la
campagne présidentielle à l'occasion
notamment de la coop 26 mathon vers un
retour massif du nucléaire dans un pays
comme la france est ce compatible avec
le projet de réindustralisation posco
vite de notre économie on en parle tout
de suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
qui nous a rejoint sur ce plateau c'est
l'édito échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques mercier avec nous en
direct sur rt france tout d'abord
jacques qui est à blâmer pour le semi
échec de la coop 26 à glasgow est ce que
ces landes où la chine comme on l'a
entendu alors il ya quand même beaucoup
d'hypocrisie dans toutes les histoires
parce que si on regarde les volumes des
émissions par habitant de ces deux pays
ils sont très faibles l'un d'eux doit
être autour de 1 8 tonne par habitant la
chine autour de 7 tonnes et demi alors
que les etats-unis sont à 16 tonnes le
canada à 17 le japon à 13 donc on voit
il ya quand même une très très grande
différence on voit où sont véritablement
les pollueurs par ailleurs il ya un
point qui est intéressant c'est la place
relativement basse de la france mais ça
on va en reparler scellier effectivement
au nucléaire après il est vrai aussi que
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu
d'engagement ferme sur les stratégies
des uns et des autres oui c'est un vrai
problème est là effectivement les
indiens et les chinois n'ont pas voulu
s'engager genou a ajouté quand même que
cette hypocrisie elle ne concernait pas
simplement l'inde et la chine il ya
aussi une hypocrisie au sein de l'union
européenne parce qu' un certain nombre
de pays se refuse à classer l'énergie
nucléaire parmi les énergies décarbonées
pour autant ils sont bien contents
d'acheter de l'électricité produite par
l'énergie nucléaire à condition que
cette énergie que cette électricité ne
soit pas produit chez eux comme nos amis
allemands par exemple elle a fort bien
fixer les choses qui dans le monde
aimait le plus de co2 alors ça dépend
comment on va le calcul et si on
commence par calculé ça je dirais par
habitant dans voilà c'est tout à fait
évident vous voyez des pays en
développement comme l'inde le brésil
sont très très très bas c'est normal
c'est un niveau de développement qui est
aussi extrêmement fun la chine en dépit
du fait qu'elle soit maintenant la
première économie en parité de pouvoir
d'achat reste relativement faible
7,5 tonnes par habitant est évidemment
ce sont des pays comme les etats unis le
canada qui sont de gros émetteurs et on
voit là justement ça c'est un point
intéressant que la france est d'abord
fel sensiblement sous la moyenne de
l'union européenne hélas comme je vous
l'avais dit c'est évidemment le résultat
du fait qu' une partie de notre énergie
est produit par l'énergie nucléaire
alors après si on regarde les émissions
en volume global alors là ça change
effectivement la chine là devient le
premier pollueur mondial mais c'est tout
simplement le fait de sa population sait
pas quelle elle les met beaucoup de co2
par habitant mais c'est la population on
est à plus d'un milliard 4 on voit quand
même que les etats-unis se retrouvent à
la moitié des émissions chinoises alors
qu ils sont cinq fois moins nombreux
donc ça veut bien dire qu'il y a un
problème dans le niveau d'émission des
états unis alors jacques elle est la
situation en france alors en france si
vous voulez si on regarde à l'horizon
2050 ou à l'horizon 2060 qui l'horizon
qui est retenue ben on voit que les
émissions de co2 sont quand même très
lié à notre production d'énergie et
notre production d'énergie et bien elle
est à 43 44 % assurée par le nucléaire
par l'électricité nucléaire si on y
rajoute les renouvelables alors dans les
renouvelables via tous les os lien il ya
le solaire il ya surtout l'hydraulique
ainsi vous l'électro électricité bon on
arrive à 53 54 % la part du charbon
pourquoi nous avons être un pro non
parce que le charbon est un très gros
polluants c'est un très gros émetteur de
co2 bien la part du charbon elle est
très faible c'est au tour de 3,8 pour
cent par contre il ya bien une part
importante de plus de 40% qui est lié au
pétrole et au gaz et là c'est
essentiellement la question des
transports et la question aussi de la
production d'énergie primaire telle est
la question est donc comment faire pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone alors
pour atteindre cette neutralité carbone
justement si on se projette à un horizon
2050 qui est l'horizon qui normalement
est retenue pour arriver à la neutralité
carbone on voit des choses qui sont
assez intéressantes là on a le scénario
de référence qui a été calculé par le
réseau de transport d'électricité rte
dans un rapport récent et on voit qu'il
y a des grandes économies qui seront
faites sur le logement le logement si
vous voulez c'est le secteur en bleu qui
est tout à fait en bas du graphique on
voit que l'industrie elle continue qui
étend en orange
nous rend un peu rouge
eh bien on voit que l'industrie elle
continue à accroître sa consommation et
c'est assez normal parce que ce scénario
prend en compte la réindustrialisation
au moins partielle de la france et puis
on voit quelque chose qui est très
intéressant c'est la part des transports
qui est en orange plus clair et bien on
voit que les transports actuellement
sont relativement faible mais que si on
bascule essentiellement vers une
consommation d'énergie c'est une
consommation d'énergie électrique
l'électrification des voitures l
électrification des autobus et bien ça
va augmenter donc fondamentalement si on
veut vraiment aller vers gérer cette
neutralité carbone eh bien il va falloir
que l'on accroît notre production
d'électricité
la question c'est comment on va t-on à
produire alors il ya en fait deux
scénarios qui sont étudiées le premier
scénario qui se baserait en 2050 2060
sur une énergie électrique qui serait
entièrement renouvelable s'est produite
entièrement par des moyens dits non
conventionnels l'éolien le
photovoltaïque le solaire et c'est bon
c'est le scénario le plus cher pourquoi
pas parce qu'il va falloir beaucoup
d'argent pour développer ce type de
technologie c'est aussi un scénario qui
est assez risqué parce que pour
l'instant une partie de ces technologies
reste des producteurs intermittents
energy corse n'est pas devant ben il n'y
a pas d'électricité dans les éoliennes
et le solaire c'est bien beau mais la
nuit ça produit pas d'énergie bon donc
là il ya un vrai problème et puis il ya
un autre scénario qui est basé plutôt
sur un mélange de entre les énergies
renouvelables et l'énergie nucléaire ce
scénario est nettement moins cher
puisqu'on passe de environ 1100
milliards pour le premier scénario à
autour de 800 milliards pour le deuxième
mais là il va falloir évidemment
reconstruire de nouvelles centrales
parce que il ya une partie des centrales
qui ont été construites dans les années
75 à 85 90 qui sont maintenant vieille
et qui arrivent en fin de vie
opérationnelle et à quel coût justement
alors voilà ça c'est la question est est
l'une des erreurs que l'on commet
fréquemment c'est de considérer que seul
le coût de production de l'énergie va
être pris en compte non alors il ya donc
cette production d'énergie avec ces deux
scénarios 1100 milliards pour le
renouvelable total un mélange
renouvelables et nucléaire autour de 770
à 800 milliards mais il ya aussi la
nécessité de faire d'énormes économies
d'énergie dans le logement cela
coûterait à l'horizon 2050
1200 milliards et puis après il faut
pommier si on veut avoir des voitures
électriques mais il faut construire des
infractions alors que ce soit des
voitures électriques ou des voitures à
hydrogène mais il va falloir construire
des infrastructures d'approvisionnement
sur les autoroutes sur les routes sans
encore ça coûte une somme importante
autour de 240 milliards au total on est
autour d'une dépense supplémentaire de
l'ordre de 60 milliards d'euros par an
hors inflation évidemment par la
toujours en euros constants donc de 60
milliards par an d'ici 2050 2060 alors
pensez vous justement la lumière de tous
ces éléments que le gouvernement
choisisse sa stratégie oui je pense que
aujourd'hui
une nette inflexion vers une relance du
secteur nucléaire on l'a entendu
emmanuel macron l'a dit lors de son
allocution du 9 novembre dernier donc là
où il est clair on va retourner d'une
certaine manière le nucléaire est ce que
maintenant on a bien pris la mesure de
ce qu'il va falloir faire en terme
d'investissement là par contre j'ai un
certain doute pourquoi parce que ça veut
dire qu'il faudra que l'on augmente de 3
points la part des investissements dans
le pib nous sommes aujourd'hui à 23% il
faudrait qu'on monte autour de 26 voire
27% certaines années alors oui c'est
possible mais pas avec les méthodes
actuelles de financement de
l'investissement il faudra probablement
revenir aux méthodes que nous utilisions
dans les années 60 et dans les années 70
est-ce que c'est compatible avec l'union
européenne faire c'est ça aussi un
véritable problème alors on l'état non
mais on peut aussi penser que d'une
certaine manière les règles européennes
pourraient bouger elle pourrait changer
dans les années qui viennent et ça ça
sera l'un des grands débats et je crois
que c'est un débat qu'il faut même avoir
tout de suite en france il faut que les
différents candidats sangatte a demandé
même a exigé à l'union européenne de
changer ses règles de financement car si
cela n'est pas fait eh bien on voit très
bien que on n'arrivera pas à faire la
transition
écologique et la transition énergétique
dans les règles actuelles de l'union
européenne et ça ça pourrait vouloir
dire la mort de l'union européenne à
terre merci beaucoup jacques pour cette
analyse qui donne une fois encore à
réfléchir merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine
le secours catholique a publié ce matin
son rapport annuel sur l'état de la
pauvreté en france malgré les aides
publiques et contrairement aux annonces
du président mais cran dans le cadre du
quoi qu'il en coûte les plus démunis
resterait pénalisé tony pitaro pour les
explications nous sommes l'un des seuls
pays du monde où le pouvoir d'achat a
continué à progresser en moyenne et où
la pauvreté n'a pas augmenté
et pourtant près de 10 % des français se
sont rendus dans des centres dead
alimentaire en 2020 selon le rapport du
secours catholique publié ce jeudi
jusqu'à 7 millions de personnes ont
demandé l'an passé une aide pour se
nourrir autre inquiétude pour les plus
pauvres le budget mensuel des personnes
ayant eu recours au secours catholique
est en baisse avec 737 euros par mois
contre 543 euros en 2019 soit des
montants largement inférieur au seuil
d'extrême pauvreté qui s'élève à 7 139
euros des chiffres qui font bondir la
présidente de l'association
c'est une humiliation que notre pays
inflige à près de 10% de sa population
selon une autre étude de l'institut des
politiques publiques
le niveau de vie des 5% de français les
plus pauvres a même diminué depuis le
début du quinquennat d' emmanuel macron
les classes moyennes quant à elles ont
vu leur niveau de vie légèrement
progressé à savoir de 1,1 pour cent à un
peu plus de 2%
quant aux grands gagnants depuis le
début du quinquennat ce sont les 1 % de
français les plus riches dont le niveau
de vie a grimpé de 2,8 pour cent et pour
en parler nous sommes avec jean baptiste
eyraud porte parole de l'association
droit au logement bonsoir jean m evo
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france plus d'un quart donc un des
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire du
secours catholique qui ne mangent pas
pendant une journée entière ou davantage
de manière régulière c'est ce que nous
disent ce rapport c'est une situation
très alarmante vous en rendez compte
aussi vous mêmes sur le terrain
écouter effectivement façon ou un mois
de plus en plus de sans abri mon autre
pays et on voit aussi des personnes qui
viennent à nos permanences qui ont du
mal à boucler les fins de mois parce que
ils doivent payer le loyer sont des
charges fixes qui sont très élevés
malgré des conditions de logement qui
sont très dégradées ça va aussi bien
pour des jeunes des étudiants
qui n'ont pas à bras qui ont des petites
ressources et qui sont insuffisamment
aidés par leurs familles on a aussi des
familles et des enfants qui ne m'arrive
pas à boucler les fins de mois qui ont
qui doivent payer donc comme je les dis
des loyers chers dans un contexte où les
appels ont été considérablement rogné ou
le rap et mais aussi avec des charges de
chauffage d'énergie qui sont de plus en
plus élevé avec la flambée donc de
l'énergie qu'on observe récemment et
puis dans un contexte où les on va dire
des revenus parce que on peut pas parler
que de salaire on voit bien qu'il ya une
précarisation également des statuts
salariaux et avec le développement par
exemple
d'aider des emplois précaires la
précarité de l'emploi bien des auto
entrepreneurs qui sont en fait qu'ils
vont travailler à la tâche et qui
notamment en 2020 avec de confinement
ont eu d'énormes difficultés des
difficultés pour pour
boucler les fins de mois donc on sent
nous une pression
non nos permanences qui traduisent soul
et un renforcement de la précarité
évidemment je virais les choses plutôt
sous l'ongle du logement puisque
je compte c'est le sujet sur lequel nous
intervenons et sur lequel nous essayons
d'aider les personnes et sur lesquels
nous essayons également d'encourager les
personnes à se mobiliser pour défendre
leurs droits un logement décent donc on
fait pas on va dire l'action humanitaire
on est plutôt sur une action de type
syndicale c'est à dire dont assez que
les gens s'associent pour des pour
défendre
l'endroit est le g convenablement mais
on le sait ils disent dans le sens ya
vraiment une une
pauvreté quoi qui s'installe et qui
touchent plus largement que ce qu'on a
connu ces 20 dernières années toute
manière on le voit aussi
le statut des sans abri a changé c'est
plus les mêmes depuis
l'année voire même une quarantaine
d'années on est c'est fini le clochard
les personnes qui sont à la rue ce sont
des personnes qui sont des victimes
directes de la crise du logement et donc
on a vu sous mac rond on a vu augmenter
le nombre de sans abri la fondation
abbé-pierre fait état de 300 milles sans
abri sans compter 100 mille personnes
qui vivent dans les habitats de
dégagement de fortune et donc la jambe
et teyran pardonnez moi vous dites sous
mac rond vous nous avez donné déjà des
premières pistes on les a bien entendu
mais ça veut dire quoi qu'il ya des
mesures politiques
mais aussi la pandémie un peu des deux
quels sont
les coûts sont que
les causes sur la question du logement
que je connais
mais sur la question que général de la
pauvreté on a vu se dégrader les
conditions de vie d'une partie de la
population c'est ce que montrent les
statistiques que vous avez présenté
également le rapport du sud du secours
catholique
on peut l'expliquer par une
paupérisation d'une part qui est liée à
une baisse des salaires parce que pour
nous tous qui est votre aux
entrepreneurs etc a emmené forcément
n'amène pas forcément à une hausse des
revenus bon donc une précarisation des
revenus et puis d'autre part des mesures
aussi gouvernementales qui ont été
prises et qui ont directement impacté le
porte monnaie les ménages modestes au
delà de l'augmentation des sans abri qui
est le fait le plus visible si vous
voulez le plus marquant mais on a aussi
une augmentation des charges fixes et
particulièrement du loyer qui est la
conséquence il ya deux effets ou par la
baisse des apl puisque le gouvernement
depuis 2010 est lorsqu'il a annoncé
le coup de rabot de 5 euros pour
l'ensemble des allocataires
de l'allocation logement et bien a
continué a poursuivi une politique très
agressive de réduction des appels d'aidé
des allocations logement donc ça a
augmenté alors résultat des courses si
vous voulez on peut considérer que les
locataires ont perdu en moyenne 1 depuis
2010 est en moyenne entre 40 et 60 euros
par mois ce qui représente
et pourtant jean baptiste eyraud
pardonnez-moi le président macron
affirmé encore récemment que la pauvreté
n'avait pas augmenté en france chiffres
également à l'appui de l'insee qui dit
en gros que le pouvoir d'achat plutôt
augmenté 1 que les mesures de soutien
prises par le gouvernement pendant la la
pandémie ont été extrêmement positifs
qui croire c'est vrai
moi je vous donne des éléments objectifs
1 les travaux successifs sur les apl
entraîné forcément une baisse de une
baisse moyenne tous les 10 de 40 à 60
euros par allocataire par mois donc
forcément
les locataires ont plus de difficultés
et on les locataires sont pas remis et
sur tout ce qui touche la ps sont parmi
les ménages les plus pauvres que nous
avons en france donc là une attaque
frontale sur des revenus des locataires
les plus modestes c'est c'est une
économie d'ailleurs encore là on vient
de le regarder les chiffres on voit
qu'il ya encore une économie
supplémentaire de 450 millions d'euros
qui a été fait sur les sur les sur les
allocations logement puisque on a une
inflation 3% à peu près de 3% cette
année peut-être plus vers la fin de
l'année mais
les appels ont été gelés c'est à dire
qu'il ya une économie objective concrète
de 450 millions d'euros pour l'état on a
eu aussi
globalement pour l'année 2000 21 on peut
considérer que
tout près de 4 milliards une économie de
près de 4 milliards d'euros a été fait
sur le dos des locataires les plus
modestes oui c'est cet exemple illustre
à serait bien la situation et puis
globalement on sait n'oublions pas que
l'état les pouvoirs publics gagne de
plus en plus d'argent sur la cherté du
logement la montée des loyers des prêts
d'immobilier les prix du foncier grâce
aux taxes différents impôts qui sont
prélevées mais que par ailleurs ils
dépensent de moins en moins d'argent
pour sa politique du logement ça fait
que et bien résultat des courses on a de
plus en plus de gens qui vont à boucler
les fins de mois qui vont aller là là
que dans les dispositifs de solidarité
alimentaire et ça c'est dramatique et
comme le dit la président du secours
catholique c'est humiliant pour ces
millions de personnes qui sont kinky
pour se nourrir pour satisfaire ce
besoin fondamental sont obligés d'aller
mendier en quelque sort bien sûr merci
beaucoup en tout cas voici qu'est
factuel merci beaucoup à jean baptiste
eyraud d'avoir été avec en direct sur rt
france
la fracture numérique s'invite dans la
campagne présidentielle sans connexion
il est difficile de pouvoir effectuer
des démarches administratives ou
médicales un mot c'est un immeuble de 11
copropriétaires qui se retrouvent sans
connexion depuis quatre mois en
isolement numérique qui pose bien des
problèmes un sujet signé renaud par
québec pierre qui sévit hivernaux
pierre a emménagé dans son appartement
flambant neufs en juillet dernier mais
depuis plus de quatre mois il est sans
connexion internet
résultat ils se retrouvent sans accès
téléphonique sans accès à la toile et
sans possibilité de pouvoir bénéficier
d'une offre de chaînes payantes ce
retraité bénévole dans une association
humanitaire international est bloqué
dans sa communication quotidienne
aujourd'hui j'ai 50 % de communication
qui est endommagé puisque aujourd'hui si
vous voulez aujourd'hui on n'a fait que
internet deviennent si vous voulez à un
moyen de communication au niveau mondial
et pas accès j'ai pas accès ni à travers
mon ordinateur j'ai pas accès ni à
travers mon téléviseur je suis désolé
mais c'est pas acceptable
je suis vice-président enfin past
président d'une association humanitaire
est bon bien souvent j'ai des opérations
à faire notamment avec l'étranger et je
suis anti kiné avec ça j'ai l'impression
que orange ne se rend pas compte du
du service qu'il doit rendre à l'homme
le promoteur de cet immeuble multiplie
les démarches depuis sa livraison en
juillet dernier sans pour autant avoir
de date précise sur l'entamé des travaux
et du raccordement vous êtes avides de
vie sains pour le réseau adsl et un pour
le réseau fibré pour une somme globale
de 6100 euros et environ au centime près
et devait réaliser ces travaux pour
juillet à la date de livraison aux
différents acquéreurs et malheureusement
nous sommes en novembre et les travaux
n'ont toujours pas été réalisée si fait
si bien qu' aucun locataire propriétaire
résidant ne peut bénéficier du téléphone
de l'internet du réseau qui peut être en
droit est effectivement avoir dans cette
ville de seine-et-marne ses 11 co
propriétaires se bat toujours pour avoir
accès à internet certains se sont même
isolé et devrait demander une
compensation à orange la fracture
numérique touche bel et bien les grandes
villes du pays et pourrait peut-être
devenir l'un des enjeux de la prochaine
campagne présidentielle
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi rendez vous à
partir de lundi à 20h d'ici là n'oubliez
pas de réagir de commenter de poser vos
questions de nous raconter vos histoires
même pour qu'en pensent les français le
télégramme d'ayrté france est à votre
écoute prochain point sur l'actualité
dans une trentaine de minutes
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descende des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins germains maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu es descendu
sa joie sur europe 1 a révélé nous un
secret vous en avez mangé du mammouth je
me trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis
un beau matin dans le trou que j'avais